et la photo du haut ça représente nos
deux filles s'est mis dans quel sens
assez du temps et puis dans les yeux
c'est la nappe est là bas c'est marion
[Musique]
où
c'est pas notre procès à nous en fait
nous les filles sont mortes sauvagement
ya rien qui veut les emmener
quelqu'un soit leur état alors peut-être
que ça fait partie de l'histoire de la
france mais nous non dans l'histoire de
la france avec des morts comme ça c'est
totalement glorieux quoi donc y en a qui
en ont besoin de ce procès mais nous on
en a pas besoin
[Musique]
un matin j'ai eu envie de décrire tout
ce qui tout ce qui nous est arrivé tout
ce qui nous a été enlevé à nous aux
filles et fallait que je l'écrive
si j'avais fait besoin là tout
simplement eric a participé
et voilà donc on écrit tout ce qu'on
tout ce qu'on a vu tout ce qu'on a pensé
tout nos réactions et notre vie
maintenant
[Musique]